we are learning more about the eight
victims six of them asian women in the
atlanta area spa shootings on tuesday
memorials were set up at the sites of
the attacks and investigators say the
suspect
denies any racial motivation but given
how targeted the attacks were many are
pointing to the long history of racism
and sexism against asian women a new
report found that asian american women
were the victims in
68 percent of hateful incidents against
asian americans in the last year
sun young choi moro is the executive
director of the national agent
asian rather pacific american women's
forum and joins us to discuss
thank you so much for joining us i want
to start with what the suspect is saying
that it's not about race this is about a
sexual addiction
but given the targets of the attacks and
given the the people that were attacked
does that make sense to you no
it doesn't make sense to me um it
doesn't make sense to most of us
in the community partly because that's
also not necessarily
how racism works in this country it is
sometimes about
the individual act of racism that people
perpetuate but often it's because of the
structural racism that there are part of
and as you mentioned
earlier there is a long arc of
racialized
sexism racialized misogyny that's
directed at
asian american women that's at play and
so
you cannot separate the two in the
incident that that that took place in
atlanta
sung young we keep hearing that racism
is experienced differently
in some cases for asian american women
in a hyper
sexual way what do you mean exactly by
that
yeah you know that's really the most
common way that asian american women
experience racism in this country it
always has a sexual
undertone well not always but oftentimes
thought
it does like what like what
what like so for example um
you know when when i am you know when i
experience public harassment um around
covid
it's not just about me being asian it's
also about me being
a woman right um and the
you know the kind of experiences we have
in terms of sexual harassment it is not
just sexual harassment
it's often very racialized right so for
example
you know when i first immigrated to this
country um i came when i was 18 years
old
and i would often get stopped by men and
who would ask me
are you korean and then if i would say
yes then they would
you know launch into you know some
korean phrase they know
and then how much they love korea and
you know they served in the military and
how i remind them
of some girlfriend they had and then say
something really inappropriate right
like
that is the kind of ways we experience
racialized sexism in this country
how would you say that that pop culture
has influenced the way we see asian
american women
well i think history has informed pop
culture and pop culture
is you know emulated those stereotypes
right and
and i think the way it plays out often
is in the way
we um appropriate our cultural
um you know outfits and costumes and you
see that a lot at halloween right
and sort of exotifying um our look
you know even in the way that people do
makeup um
and you know those things are
perpetuated in our in a
broadly in our mainstream culture i'm
looking for education too
sonya and i was talking to a friend of
mine who's asian and said many times
people think
submissive or timid or
very open to engaging at in sexual acts
because it was said so by a man do you
think that there is something to that i
want people to really understand
what's being said here i don't want us
to dance around this i think this is
so important i think many people don't
know what is happening in this country
and how serious it is yeah and you know
we've got to go all the way to
the to the beginning of you know asian
american women
being in uh in the united states right
you know go all the way back to 1875
the page act right what it did basically
assumed that people that looked like me
east asian women
were coming to the united states for the
sole purpose of prostitution
so off the bat you know our existence in
this country has always been framed
around
the hypo hypersexualization of
our bodies and our our our logs and then
you know
move along a couple centuries and you
know in you know
into the militarization of
you know the pacific uh rim you know the
asian pacific
um where korea you know okinawa
philippines vietnam where you know the
u.s military personnel have gone there
and again you know really commodified
asian american women
for their pleasures their desires and
bring those ideas and fetishes
and fantasies back to the united states
and continue to
perpetuate that on those of us who live
here young what do we need to take away
from this moment
we need to take away from this moment
that you know
i'm glad that we're starting to have
this conversation but this cannot be
it asian american women have been long
invisible in the society
right you know we're being told this is
not a racist incident
it is a racist incident because of the
way asian-american women experience
racism in our country
and so what i want us to walk away from
is
that all of us find a way to talk about
what happened
in atlanta in a way that honors the
women
who whose lives were taken too soon in a
very tragic way
and to understand and connect the
political and historical
context in which um that tragedy took
place
sung young choi moro we want to continue
this conversation too and we will thank
you for being with us